CAME TO FACEBOOK.
JOHN AVLON WITH A REALITY CHECK.
>> IN A SENATE THAT OFTEN SEEMS
PROUDLY DYSFUNCTIONAL,
YESTERDAY'S HEARING ON FACEBOOK
SEEMED LIKE A THROWBACK TO A
MORE BIPARTISAN ERA.
NOW, UNFORTUNATELY FOR FACEBOOK,
THE SENATORS' COMMON GROUND WAS
A RESOUNDING DISLIKE OF THEIR
BUSINESS PRACTICES.
BUT COVERING GOVERNING CAN
STRAIN PEOPLE'S ATTENTION, EVEN
WHEN THE TARGET FOR REFORM IS
DECLARED ONE OF THE MOST
POWERFUL CORPORATE GIANTS IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
ACCORDING TO ONE LAWMAKER, WHOSE
PRODUCTS HARM CHILDREN, STOKE
DIVISION, AND WEAKEN OUR
DEMOCRACY.
NOW, LET'S CUT THROUGH THE NOISE
AND LOOK AT THREE SOCIAL MEDIA
REFORMS THAT SEEM TO BE
GATHERING TRACTION ACROSS
PARTISAN LINES.
NOW, THE FIRST BIG POINT OF
CONSENSUS SEEMS TO BE THE REFORM
OF SECTION 230.
THAT'S THE LAW THAT SHIELDS
PLATFORMS LIKE FACEBOOK FROM
LAWSUITS ON THE BASIS OF CONTENT
POSTED BY USERS.
>> I THINK THAT IT WILL BE THIS
CONGRESS AND THIS SUBCOMMITTEE
THAT IS GOING TO LEAD THE WAY TO
ONLINE PRIVACY, DATA SECURITY,
SECTION 230 REFORMS.
>> HOLD BIG TECH ACCOUNTABLE BY
REFORMING SECTION 230.
>> NOW, THE FACT THAT
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS SEEM
TO OPPOSE SECTION 230 FOR VASTLY
DIFFERENT REASONS IS AN IRONY TO
TALK ABOUT ANOTHER DAY.
BUT THE STAR WITNESS, FRANCES
HAUGEN, HAD A USELY NUANCED AND
TARGETED TAKE ON THE APPROACH TO
REFORM.
>> REFORMING SECTION 230 TO
EXEMPT DECISIONS ABOUT
ALGORITHMS, RIGHT, SO MODIFYING
230 AROUND CONTENT I THINK
HAS -- IT IS VERY COMPLICATED
BECAUSE USER GENERATED CONTENT
IS SOMETHING THAT COMPANIES HAVE
LESS CONTROL OVER.
THEY HAVE 100% CONTROL OVER
THEIR ALGORITHMS.
AND FACEBOOK SHOULD NOT GET A
FREE PASS ON CHOICES IT MAKES TO
PRIORITIZE GROWTH AND VIRALITY
AND REACTIVENESS OVER PUBLIC
SAFETY.
THEY SHOULDN'T GET A FREE PASS
ON THAT.
THEY'RE PAYING FOR THEIR PROFITS
NOW WITH OUR SAFETY.
SO I STRONGLY ENCOURAGE REFORM
OF 230.
>> NOW, THE STATED FOLKS AT THE
HEARING WAS PROTECTING KIDS
ONLINE, SPURRED BY INTERNAL
FACEBOOK RESEARCH SHOWING THAT
IT KNEW INSTAGRAM COULD BE TOXIC
FOR YOUNG GIRLS WITH BODY IMAGE
ISSUES.
>> SO YOU AGREE THAT CONGRESS
HAS TO ENACT THE SPECIAL
PROTECTIONS FOR CHILDREN AND
TEENS TO STOP SOCIAL MEDIA
COMPANIES FROM MANIPULATING
YOUNG USERS AND THREATENING
THEIR WELL-BEING.
TELL ME IF THIS SHOULD PASS,
ONE, CREATE AN ONLINE ERASER
BUTTON SO YOUNG USERS CAN TELL
WEBSITES TO DELETE THE DATA THEY
HAVE COLLECTED ABOUT THEM, TWO,
GIVE YOUNG TEENS UNDER THE AGE
OF 16 AND THEIR PARENTS CONTROL
OF THEIR INFORMATION, AND,
THREE, BAN TARGETED ADS TO
CHILDREN?
>> I SUPPORT ALL THOSE ACTIONS.
>> OKAY, THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
TALK OF RAISING THE AGE
REQUIREMENTS FOR SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNTS TO 16 COULD TAKE THE
DAMAGING PSYCHOLOGICAL EFFECTS
OF SOCIAL MEDIA OUT OF
ELEMENTARY AND MIDDLE SCHOOL.
PROVIDED THAT THE AGE LIMITS IS
ACTUALLY ENFORCED.
IT WOULD CREATE PROTECTIONS FOR
THE SALE OF MINORS' DATA AND
OPEN THE DOOR TO FEDERAL PRIVACY
REGULATIONS.
DESPITE THE OPPOSITION TO NEW
REGULATIONS, THERE EVEN SEEMED
TO BE OPENNESS TO THE NEED FOR
MORE TRANSPARENCY VIA GOVERNMENT
OVERSIGHT.
>> WHAT CHANGES WOULD YOU
IMMEDIATELY INSTITUTE?
>> I WOULD IMMEDIATELY ESTABLISH
A POLICY OF HOW TO SHARE
INFORMATION AND RESEARCH FROM
INSIDE THE COMPANY WITH
APPROPRIATE OVERSIGHT BODIES
LIKE CONGRESS.
I WOULD GIVE PROPOSED
LEGISLATION TO CONGRESS SAYING
HERE'S WHAT AN EFFECTIVE
OVERSIGHT AGENCY WOULD LOOK
LIKE.
>> A REGULATORY AGENCY WITHIN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
>> YES.
>> YESTERDAY'S HEARING WAS
MERCIFULLY FREE OF THE USUAL
HYPERPARTISAN GRANDSTANDING.
INSTEAD, IT WAS SUBSTANTIVE AND
DARE I SAY EVEN SERIOUS.
SOME SENATORS SEEMED TO GET
NOSTALGIC.
>> THE CONVERSATION SO FAR
REMINDS ME THAT YOU AND I OUGHT
TO RESOLVE OUR DIFFERENCES AND
INTRODUCE LEGISLATION, SO AS
SENATOR THUNE SAID, LET'S GO TO
WORK.
>> OUR DIFFERENCES ARE VERY
MINOR, THEY SEEM VERY MINOR IN
THE FACE OF THE REVELATIONS THAT
WE HAVE NOW SEEN, SO I'M HOPING
WE CAN MOVE FORWARD.
>> I SHARE THAT VIEW, CHAIRMAN,
THANK YOU.
>> CONGRESS COULD ONLY BOTTLE
THAT BRIEF GLIMPSE OF BIPARTISAN
RESOLVE, AND APPLY IT TO, SAY,
AVOIDING A DISASTROUS DEFAULT ON
OUR DEBT, OR PASSING
INFRASTRUCTURE REFORM, AND
ELECTION REFORM OR HAVING A
BIPARTISAN COMMISSION TO
INVESTIGATE THE JANUARY 6th
ATTACK.
NAH, THAT'S TOO MUCH TO ASK.
BUT REFORMING SOCIAL MEDIA'S
DAMAGING EFFEC